my name is minalis diese and i am 22
years old and i was born and raised in
the bronx
i wasn't the average kid my my vision
got really bad
really young i turned 16 and i go to the
eye doctor
that appointment like changed my life
completely and they told me
the way your vision is you have eye
disease now
that it's gonna quadruple every three
years
they literally told me i would waste my
mother's money if i went to school
and i told my mother the same exact
words that they told me
and she just told me you're fine you're
gonna be good just go to school
and do it so i went to school and i did
everything and i actually
i graduated first in my class while
being blind
my biggest situation is my mother
and just when i think about like the
things that she went through
and how she grew up and she didn't have
anything it makes me work so hard so i
can give her everything
and i know i will she raised a hustler
and i'm just very blessed to have the
mother that i do
my living situation right now i live
with my mom and my two sisters in a
two-bedroom apartment i've lived in this
apartment for
my entire life and i'm 22 and nothing
has changed it looks the complete
same as fashion as i am
i want the space to feel relaxed to feel
like that sound i don't want it like and
i can't escape it because i'm in new
york city
my brain i feel like my brain has 800
tabs open
at the same exact time so since i'm
always on go
and i'm always working on a project or
this or email whatever
i would like the space around me to just
zen
color because obviously color but sun
okay she's here
[Applause]
i am so excited to finally meet you
i have seriously seriously
been thinking about you let's start at
your site let's start there yes
that's right so i've struggled with my
site my entire life
um i've been legally blind for a long
time
and in august i was told by doctors
once again that if i didn't get a
procedure done
by this year i would be completely blind
by 26
and i'm only 22 and i need my eyes to
design
so i went into panic mode because i
didn't have the means
to pay for the surgery so i
posted it on instagram and i don't have
a big following but i posted it on
instagram
with the hopes that even if i get a
hundred dollars
me like i'll figure something out you
know like i'll make something happen
so i posted it and the post
did really well and i didn't expect it
to and in less than 48 hours i received
5 600. i only needed 5 000.
so that within itself allowed me to
realize that people believe in me
you know people believe in my story and
and
it taught me that we're each other's
greatest networking tool and i can't get
anywhere
without other people so then i started
that
ignited me to start my company and i
made my company which is called c2c
and it's a networking event company
college created to create
because i believe that we all create
something and
it can be artistic it can be a
spreadsheet but you're making something
and we need each other to create
a better world so yeah what i love is
that
when i hear a success story i'm just
like
then i'm glad that person was brave
enough
and had the hope enough to put it out
there and yet
the outcome to me is just
proof in humanity and then what i love
is that then that was your springboard
to start a business
so i've always my entire life my mother
knows my sisters know i've always said
that i was gonna be a designer
and i've always thought i was gonna have
my company i didn't know how but
it was gonna happen and i always say
that it's all over my instagram my
captions are
i don't know how but it will i'm
everywhere so
once that happened it changed me and you
can't just go through things like that
in life and and not change
you know i'm very young but just
battling that i can wake up one day and
i can't see anything
when i draw for a living it was a lot um
and i didn't want to open up to
instagram
it was a lot for me to open up to
instagram as a blogger you know
a mini blogger i was in shock
when i had to that was the only way my
insurance covered my surgery
after i was blind so after i went fully
blind
my insurance would pay that is uh
a broken system yes uh and
what i think also people want
to hear is that if you donate it is not
just
money going into nowhere but it
can actually help and fix someone's
very important challenges but the hope
and the incentivization that you took
that and then built a business out of it
so not only did it like
support you but it catapulted you
into the next chapter and i'm here to
tell you some people don't recognize
that change is necessary and they can
stay stuck so at your age to know that
that is incredible wisdom
thank you it's true when i leave this
earth i want to know that i did
everything that i could to help others
i'm getting emotional oh my god don't
even get me started on your mom
okay but i i just want to help others
you know so
i believe the meaning of life is that
we're here to take care of each other
yeah so i totally subscribe to your
thinking
thank you i love your story with your
mom thank you
i love that you're so influenced and you
give her the credit
and that she inspires you to be who you
are
tell me about the space that you live in
currently and have for your whole life
literally my whole life um so i was
born in the box and i live in this space
that i live in right now
since the day i was born and it has not
changed
yes that is it it's the same it's orange
so it matches my aesthetic of my orange
but then it has not changed
my mom has ran a daycare out of this
apartment and you live
in this place with your mom and your two
sisters which means the four of you
i looked at your pinterest inspirations
my life
and i loved your boards they really
spoke to me i totally get your style
and um i also got the uh
quotes that you sent in i've brought you
into my home
because there was one in particular that
i pulled out
and i put it on my mirror in my
little like bathroom closet area
and it has really helped me and my life
so much
in return i wanted to actually give you
this because
i went and researched so here is a quote
that i made
for you no way thank you so much yeah
read it out loud please okay working
hard for something we don't care about
is called stress working hard for
something we love
is called passion isn't that great we
all run around like chickens with our
heads cut off
sweating the small stuff freaking out
about every little thing
we also you know get really freaked out
about work stuff
and we don't know when this is like
we're doing this to ourselves and it's
by choice and it's a dream and a goal we
have
or it's just something we have to do
because there's always going to be that
in work
and i really wanted to do something uh
special for you
that the whole family can enjoy and okay
so it's on the screen this was
your living room yes i i've seen this
a lot all right here we go let's do it
i said it was your living room i know
that's why i said wait okay good
no way
welcome home thank you come on in
this is crazy here go right over there
to your new table
this is my table that is your table my
grandfather made this table in dominican
republic
we were like we're not touching the
table we're just going to work around it
and we love it and it's an heirloom it's
your family
and we added some new chairs and those
are little flower home prints over there
of flowers
which i know you love this we got from
an amazing
etsy vendor and i took all of the colors
from your pinterest boards i noticed you
loved
green and rust which is an amazing color
combination
one other thing that i wanted to do was
i changed the orange color and brought
it into
the couch because i thought it would
brighten and lighten the room
because there is the one window so you
only have one light source
we also wanted to do sort of a
lightening of the floor
because that has such a tremendous
effect and then we have this
uh beautiful light that's going to come
here i also
took um your quotes and i put them
at our amazing art department
goddess her name is sarah and she has a
two-month-old baby right now
and somehow she just makes miracles
happen
so her and i co-conspired thank you sir
and she
made all of these herself and they're
some of your favorite quotes
yeah and just sort of the plants and
just shift the chi
a little bit with light and living
things after 22 years
we're shifting the chief that's also
your tv console
and we put new handles on it so that you
could have
this is it yeah this is so creepy yeah
we went into your home took your
furniture
and speaking of this whole set is going
to go
from here in a truck to storage
go to your house pick up the rest of
your stuff
painters are going to come in crazy and
paint the entire room
this color no more orange walls no more
orange walls
fresh curtains they're going to hang
everything and do it exactly like this
so you don't have to do a thing
it'll just be a perfect seamless
transfer
thank you this segment for me and
getting to know you over these last few
weeks
was so much more than about decor
yeah it's who you are as a person and
those stories are really incentivizing
for us all to take the high road
there's less traffic so i'm all about
that the killing
and i just think that the way your mom
raised you to make you so brave and
clear-headed
and smart and bold in a time that can be
so
confusing and overwhelming is just
well you really inspired me thank you if
anyone is
liking any aspect of this room you can
go to our website
and sort of take a look-see uh
at what we did but really we just wanted
to say
we think you're awesome thank you thank
you i appreciate this oh my god i wish i
could hug you so badly
honestly me too but like six feet thank
you so much
uh minalise for coming on the show yes
thank you for telling us your story
most of all thank you for being you
[Music]